I'm
Zakusu Ryuzo.  What are you going to do?
That's the line here.
The ring finger
is that he's a
hotel
therma.  I don't think
everyone is calm,
everyone is a magic court grandmother,
but I don't respect them separately
, so don't push your values on me. I think it's
long expedition with Sax.  It seems that the image has changed a lot during that time.
Ah
, I'm like you and I, so
let's get along
with each other.
You're even a ring finger girl of made a
Goofy Zurawa who doesn't seem to think of anything like Omae
There's a grave with only high tension.
If it fits in with the cool mouth of the moody change, I
think I'm going to wear
it. Then I'm only motivated.
Royal Nights I guess I was chosen and lived.
I came to tease you.  Huh